un homme nu avec une barbe un soldat
verdir un enfant
donc ici
bureau de tabac le mardi et le week-end
semaine alternative
maintenant [ __ ]
avec les devoirs
Poubelle à ordure
comment ça s'appelle parce que les gens gardent
mobile et c'est la chose
allez il nous donne des hôtes d'ici
puisque vous aimez jouer aux docteurs
Nous allons vous exclure d'un homme
apparence vulgaire comme c'est beau avec un enfant
et son mari, oui, comment il sait, c'est que je suis
sorcière
compte comme une vibe [ __ ] tout
que vous pouvez tromper les hommes qui
tu n'es dans rien
nous sommes des gens en plus de tout
la vie que tu viens à moi maintenant avec que tu
J'aime ce garçon parce que c'est une bonne personne
Je n'ai pas peur d'une sorcière aussi, mais quoi
Ils me font peur, ce sont des fils de [ __ ]